[Music]
sorry i didn't see you there
welcome back to our next pi data sponsor
interview i'm james powell
i serve as co-chair of the non-focus
board of directors and also as vice
president of pi data
today i'm joined by fred rice from ibm
center for open source ai
technologies he's going to tell us a
little bit about how ibm
uses the open source scientific
computing tools that you and i love
as well as what he does at ibm's coding
fred could you introduce yourself to the
pi data global audience
sure hi i'm fred rice and i work for ibm
in fact i've worked for ibm since 2006
and initially i worked for ibm research
but
since for the last about five years i've
worked for codate that's the center for
open source data and ai technologies
we're an open source lab that covers
foundational open source
for data and ai in the enterprise fred
can you tell us a little bit more about
the ibm center for open source data and
ai technologies
sure co-date as we like to call it is
a lab located in san francisco and we
work on
a stack of open source
tools and technologies that are
foundational
to well ai across the enterprise
and foundational to our products things
like apache spark
tensorflow and pi torch and onyx for
deep learning
the jupiter notebooks and pandas and
scikit-learn
ecosystem for model development and
exploratory analysis
as well as kubeflow for covering
end-to-end ai
on kubernetes fred i understand your
employee number one at code8
what made you so excited to start on
this new journey i
was approached by some ibm executives in
late 2014 with the opportunity to
start a new center at the time it was a
center focused on apache spark
and we called it the spark technology
center and
it was a really exciting journey from me
going from
being the first technical person on the
team to growing the team
hiring people creating our different
projects
and a really exciting journey
and i learned a whole lot and i've been
able to work with a really talented team
and it's been so much fun
working on that team now over the years
our
mission has changed a bit or rather
we've achieved more
clarity into what our mission is when we
when we started out we figured that we
would be all about apache spark
but then we found out that anyone who's
using apache spark in the enterprise
well they're using notebooks to write
their spark jobs
so you need to cover jupiter and some of
those spark jobs are going to be trading
models
so you need soft media socket learn and
tensorflow
and pi torch to work with spark
and so we started contributing to all of
those open source
projects and we started and then you
want to run spark on kubernetes so we
started working with spark
on kubernetes support and we started
getting into the early days of kubeflow
and
eventually we we stood back and we
realized
we're no longer really the spark
technology center we're a center that
covers a wide variety of different
ai tools we started with apache spark
but we had to expand
out to all the tools that you need to
make an end-to-end use case that
involves spark
actually work and so we rebranded
ourselves as co-date the center for open
source data and ai technologies and
that's where we stand today where we've
been for a number of years and i think
that better describes our mission
as it has turned out to be which is to
make this
end-to-end stack of ai technologies
all work together in an enterprise
environment
where you have a cloud to run your
compute
and where you have teams of people who
need to work together
and who need to work with the rest of
their organization there are a lot of
unique challenges that you have in the
context
of ai and scientific computing when you
move it into the enterprise
that are that are unique to enterprise
environments
and that's where we've had our focus
making this entire stack of tools
work well in this environment could you
tell us a little bit more
about the open source scientific
computing tools that are in use at ibm
and specifically which tools are
actively in use within your group in ibm
sure now ibm is a big company
and open source is has been a major part
of ibm
going back 20 30 years remember
we were the ones behind pushing linux
into the enterprise
way back then and since then we've
continued to have a lot of open source
we have i think at this point over 60
000
ibm developers who actively work with
open source
in their daily lives so on the
scientific computing side if there's an
open source package that has
any degree of use in the enterprise
chances are there's an ibm product that
uses it as a dependency or
in fact pushes it to the front as a
major feature
now my own little corner of ibm is
codeine the center for open source data
and ai technologies
and we work on a particular stack that
is central to
ai and data in the hybrid cloud
so apache spark for data processing
tensorflow
pytorch and onyx for deep learning
jupyter notebooks
and appendis data frames and things like
scikit-learn
for data analysis and exploratory
analysis
as well as kubeflow to cover getting all
these tools
onto kubernetes and making them work in
the cloud in a modern cloud
do you use pi spark as part of the stack
oh absolutely yes in fact we have a
spark committer on our team
brian cutler who did a lot of the work
behind
the high performance udfs in pi spark
the integration with apache arrow that
lets you run
user-defined functions in pi spark and
make them run really fast
um that was largely brian's working and
um
and we have continued to contribute to
spark in general but also to pi spark in
particular
moving forward because it's a really
important part of ibm we have like two
dozen project
products that use that spark internally
so it's very important for us to
maintain that strong relationship with
the community and to give that code
do you use desk at all we have
some of our developer advocates have
built
use cases around desk it is not one of
our primary
environments to contribute to just
because there isn't that much
alignment directly with ibm products but
because there's a lot of usage in the
community
our advocacy team does work with task
and shows how to do
use cases on top of desk fred do you
have a chance to
do coding day to day what's your
favorite open source
tool my favorite open source tool is
usually the one that i'm working with at
the time
so so right now we are
right on the cusp of releasing a project
we call text extensions for pandas
and that's a series of extensions to
pandas data frames
to make them a universal data structure
for
natural language processing data so i've
worked on natural language processing
off and on for about 12 years
prior to working at coda i was in the
nlp group at ibm almond research center
and what i've always seen in making nlp
applications
is that managing the data is key there
you
may you may have a model a very
sophisticated model
but the care and feeding of that model
is what your day-to-day work is all
about
and pandas i found is such a compelling
way to represent that natural language
processing data
that and such a a powerful tool for
manipulating it that it's been like
night and day for me
transitioning from the old way of doing
things writing
basically straight line code to using
pandas and now we've been contributing
to pandas
and also building around pandas
extension types for representing some of
the important concepts in natural
language processing
and we build a library like i said
called text extensions for pandas
and we're in the process of rolling that
out we've got an alpha release out
we're going to move to beta and then to
final release and it's been really
exciting building that up building out
use cases we've been talking it up
internally with our product teams
so uh yeah so to the long answer
to your question would be pandas right
now and in particular our extensions to
it text extensions for pandas is what
i'm
really excited about and working on
actively as far as coding
what is the most exciting recent
development in the open source community
for you so for for my team
a big exciting recent development is
that we have
a lot of ibm research technology around
explainability and fairness in ai that
we recently donated to
the linux foundation as the ai fairness
360 ai
explainability 360 and adversarial
robustness 360
toolkits that gives state-of-the-art
capabilities for making
ai trusted trusted and trustworthy in
the enterprise
and that getting that into the
linux foundation control where it is out
in the open under control of foundation
under good governance so that we can use
it broadly across
many different enterprises and that
members of the industrial community can
collaborate on it
that was a really big uh achievement in
our in our organization and
we're very excited about having that
technology out we in my in my own team
we've built a lot of use cases around
those uh in fact um
most recently we've ported a iphone 360
to r
uh it was a previously a purely a python
tool
and got that uh got
all of those apis accessible to our
users gabrielle
de quieros on our team is a big
major figure in the our data science
community and she and a couple other
members of our team worked on that
so we're really excited to have those
that trusted
ai portfolio now out as a completely
community building
community built project and uh
under control of the linux foundation
what improvements would you like to see
or what pain points do you
currently have with the open source
tools that you use
so there's pain points that i have and
there's pain points that
shall we say our clients our customers
our
product lines have at the big picture
in terms of pain points right now when i
speaking as the chief architect for
code8
is that we have all of these tools that
we built for data and ai
and we most of them were built before
the enterprise moved on to kubernetes
and the hybrid cloud
and a lot of our work in the last year
year and a half has been about how do we
adapt all these tools to work in this
new world of the hybrid cloud
so that's part of why we have a big
presence in the kubeflow project
which is largely about getting tools to
work in
on top of kubernetes and making ai work
better on kubernetes
but also we have had worked a lot on
getting jupiter notebooks to work
in a containerized environment for
example if you want if you start up your
jupiter lab environment
right and you have six tabs
uh unless you're careful those are all
going to run in the same machine
and so if you're training six different
models they're all going to try and grab
all those tabs are going to try and grab
the same gpu with with our
lyra project we can get each of those
tabs in your jupiter lab environment
running on a separate container under
kubernetes
and that that kind of capability really
opens up
productivity for someone who's working
on a team
with a cloud backend also another thing
that's been really important for us has
been the ability to quickly author
a collection of notebooks into a batch
job
and send that off to the cloud so
that's another part of our lyra work on
jupiter
on a more personal level um again i've
been working lately on
on pandas and uh and also more
more tightly on the python stack and
there i think the big thing
that is standing in a lot of individual
developers
ways is the global interpreter lock
your python code is kind of constrained
to be single threaded
and so if you uh if you whenever you're
working with lar
with data and ai with python
you often run into a situation where
things are going really really smoothly
and then you've got to all the sudden
transition
into la attaching the bunch of
libraries to your python stack and so
that's where i think it's really
important that we continue to move
forward with technologies like dusk and
also we've been keeping an eye on ray
and of course we have worked on getting
pi spark working better
with with the python stack
but i think that the industry as a whole
we still need to move forward on getting
parallelism to work better
in a python environment tell me fred
does your team at ibm
work on any open source projects
directly do you contribute back to any
of the
project community supported projects or
do you originate your own
extensions to jupiter lab or additional
novel
open source work all of the above
so we have we do a lot of contributions
to
community run projects so some examples
of that would be we have committers on
apache spark
we have a committer on pi torch we have
maintainers on tensorflow components we
have
the distinguished contributors which is
what they call them in
in the in the jupiter notebook space
as a result of our jupiter work and
so we do a lot of contributions to
established projects
we also establish our own projects
the for example uh the the kubeflow
operator used to be a project that we
established but then we donated that
technology to kubeflow
and then there's in between so a lot of
our work in jupiter
has been under the auspices of a project
called the lyra which started out as ibm
code in fact code that we wrote to
solve some problems that our products
had
and then we made it an ibm open source
project and then we made it a jupiter
sub project
and that's where it stayed right now
it's a jupiter sub project
and it's part of the jupiter ecosystem
and
we've been seeing functionality migrate
from aliba
to jupiter server and
that's that's great um and
so we move fluidly throughout all
different kinds of contribution both
contributing to established
community-run projects starting our own
projects
or anywhere in between and transitioning
from one mode to the next it's you know
whatever is going to get that code out
there into the hands of the people
that need to use it that's what we do
what makes ibm so motivated to help
sponsor the open source
scientific computing ecosystem and
specifically the pi data conference
series
there are several different reasons so
in a big partly because a lot of the
[Music]
users of ibm products are working with
the pi data stack
anyone who is using cloud pack for data
anyone who is using watson studio
anyone who's using our spectrum
computing high performance computing
stack
they are going to be using pi data
technology on um stuff
stuff managed by num focus under the
covers
and it's very important for us as a
company to maintain a good connection to
our users because at the end of the day
our products are about making those
users productive so that they can get
stuff done
for their employers who are the ones who
are buying this
these products from us and
having a good connection to pi data gets
us that connection to all those data
scientists and all those developers
and all those architects who are
building solutions on a daily basis
using ibm products
that's one reason that we like to be
connected strongly to the pi data
community
another reason is that we
incorporate a lot of pi data technology
in our products you know
things like jupiter and just python as a
whole
numpy is everywhere for example and
as a result of incorporating that we
also do a lot of contributions back
and if you're contributing code to
an open source project it's very
important to maintain a connection
to the community community of
contributors
and you at conferences like pi data
you'll see not just the users but also
the contributors
so we need to connect to maintain that
connection with the users
and to maintain that connection with the
contributors and of course we
also see a lot of thought leaders who
talk with the bi-data community and we
want to have a two-way communication
with them too
so it's very important to maintain a
connection to pi data
ibm sponsors uh dozens
of pi data events every year many many
meetups
the occasional conference we sometimes
donate to the projects themselves
we have a very active relationship going
back a long way
with pi data so fred i understand
ibm has directly supported linux
foundation ai specifically ai fairness
360 ai explainability360
and another initiative about model
robustness can you tell us a little bit
more about this
so ibm research has developed a lot of
technology around
in the area of trusted ai and we had
open sourced this technology as
a collection of toolkits as you were
saying ai fairness 360 ai explainability
360
adversarial robustness 360. and
these had been ibm ibm run open source
projects but
this earlier this year we donated them
to the linux foundation under the linux
foundation ai
initiative and we're really happy to
have those projects under open
governance
in general ibm is a big proponent of
open governance
we like to see all the members of the
industry working together
on open source we think that everyone
wins that way
and we're also really proud of this
technology it's an entire stack
for trusted ai for bringing trust and
transparency to ai development
for making models that aren't biased for
making models that are going to
resist attacks and generally
building up the level of trust that a
lot of our the people
the clients that we work with for
example in highly regulated industries
need to have around their models and
versions of this technology are in our
products but we think it's really
important
to have an open version and to maintain
that strong connection between them
so we're really proud to have donated
all that cutting-edge technology to the
linux foundation this year
so fred is there any final message you'd
like to leave for the pi data global
community
just that ibm remains really con
committed
to open source we've been involved
with open source for a very long time as
a
member of the community of enterprise
companies that work with open source
open source is really foundational to
our entire product line and
ibm really wants open source to be under
open governance
so that all the members of the industry
can work together
and create that open foundation and then
we can all build on top of that
and make the technologies jack work
better for everyone
thank you for joining us fred i really
enjoyed the conversation and i really
enjoyed hearing about how
ibm makes open governance a priority as
all of you know that's something that's
near and dear to my heart
and it's near and dear to the mission
the core mission of pi data and num
focus
thanks james it's been great talking
with you about open source at ibm and my
own little corner of that big
ibm open source world and we're really
happy to be here at pi data and to be
sponsoring the conference
as you know open source and open
governance are really important for ibm
just really happy to be here thanks
everybody for joining us i really
enjoyed that conversation with fred
i look forward to seeing you again in
the next sponsor interview that we do
goodbye everybody goodbye everyone
[Music]
you